hey everybody welcome to multiple
players I'm your host Chris waters this
Wiggly guy next means Rob handler we got
Tom McShay on the end of here and Sean
McGinnis a full slate of four for
goldeneye double-oh-seven on the n64
it's video game history month we want to
you know celebrate the games of our past
we've all played this game extensively
in the past but in the preliminary
rounds we've been playing what we've
come to determine is that some of us
remember better than others Chris
doesn't remember it at all which is to
say I remember very poor chris is like
how do you read road yes this'll be fun
yeah it's gonna be we should point out
that Rob Rob hold up your handicap oh no
I was gonna like that oh my goodness he
has its piece of art right here what is
the what is the company do we can defame
Mako pad 64 now we all have like
official Nintendo controllers whereas
this guy has a fun official computer
I'll take one for the team I don't want
to make it when I fry here so the way
perfect handicap Oh God God us now I'm
so sorry how's a real shitty mode okay
you know I got gonna wow I'm gonna teach
you a lesson just you know Fred and Gunn
oh no you got the body uh oh come on RT
nine mercy yeah i know that noise so
they added the are as a reference what
you were talking about Shawn be out this
is the second time I've seen you run
around with no weapon like you get into
battle with nothing I'm [ __ ] Boromir
I'll slap the [ __ ] out you do have a
mean slack where are you shotgun I know
you're still on let's see you in here no
no not in this 100 am i doing openings
I'll just shoot him up you just know
nope my ugly on that one is that you'll
run out this is not a good fight for me
to be in
yes I hope your Nona comes Joe why won't
you die 12 dog you're like a phoenix
hang out tena koe a fool oh no way oh
did I win this check that'd be
embarrassing I think Rob one he did I
got second no I got certain oh look at
that just look over there with your
goddamn eyes it's so much farther away I
lose so much for their bright the light
takes a longer time to read your
eyeballs yours not as definitely inside
of my buck oh that happens famous last
words I decided to do proximity mines on
the base I love prosperity for that but
if we look I need health left you have
no health you're literally just body
armor it's called Mariana and it helps
so much fun oh no the huge manatee oh oh
I'm trying to do that to you oh who came
in here here are so many minds not me
waiting area shitty oh my god did i win
Sean just shoot i think i just want it
with him by my teachers controller guys
that controllers Opie yeah we were all
wrong on that controller yeah decor
Alexis you can check through that bowl
you can shoot them their first ending
one so can you shoot it out of the end
the rest of the places it's gonna be
terrible good job Oh worth it that was
worth it Club dan you can lob Oh mom be
like to Rob's head with a shotgun
struggle on rocket to the dome that's
going to do it if I die battle guy
that'll kill that'll kill someone who's
who's lower right that's me oh you are
club here look like a rocket 6 no I'll
do it
haha oh you know no you did good I did I
miss like firing this watch could I
really miss Shh answers yeah you did
miss and then you walked in the fire
okay tell me cuz I'm real bad [ __ ] oh
that didn't work out free I didn't know
oh no not again I'm I the one that
happen oh yeah watch out there it's cool
creepy no this is not going well good
show yourself look there's certain
special forces yes oh you know it's
literally zero oh no oh come on is it
yeah please yeah oh my god I twist make
it yeah I'm when he kills and yet you
lost you lost I went seven points
because I he'll run teen suicide we're
gonna set up a new match it's gonna be
licensed to kill so how is it up and
died yet oh oh cuz Rob hasn't shown oh
my god you're good nope get slapped nope
welcome to star chef look at that oh
look alive this is you guys know that
this basically what a real guns light is
come in cuz you get shot one oh [ __ ]
pretty much don't worry another God here
so I promise yeah also has no bullets
come on I want to slap your face that's
cool danica meerschaum am whenever I see
Rob is always unarmed
that won't even so cool i dodge everyone
like the friggin fighting me over here
haha damage the Cougar sucks yeah you
don't worry no why because it's slow cuz
it's got a slow rate of fire yeah it's
good for 41 years you know we're all
three you uh oh that was brutal that is
that 14 this one might have a god all
right now let's just recall do you
remember when I told you the only mode i
ever played was licensed to kill that's
weird its respects a mode you ever
played look at it dude go ahead Sean
yeah just go yeah let's match you earned
it oh my god in philly to log on to
everett murder get better oh no uh-oh
nauseous oh is it still hunt was amazing
it's still on license to kill go get
your tarot mode license to kill I don't
know it's a tie wait who is this
horrible demon running around upstairs
yeah look at all your horrible deeds
you're an abomination of nature isn't
enough a tiny man with a big head wait
somebody should not shoot me I'm gonna
put ok player a lot lower left don't
shoot me oh yeah I don't know what that
don't shoot me I'm not a hidey-hole oh
look at all gross i look Marlon filming
was odd job who do you think I really
wanted everyone to see how close a weird
job sucks cuz jaws is the weirdest look
sean is just trying to salvage any
dignity he can kind of ring wow you just
forgot odd jobs you shot directly over
his head oh I'm gonna get you a job hmm
you giant jerk
oh no my watch you knew what was coming
I knew it I I respect that about you ah
damn it and we're kill I'm not going on
first Hey look you guys tied factory hi
great work GG everybody thank you guys
for playing thank you old and I double
zero and then a seven at the end of it
thank you guys for watching all multiple
players it's been fun to do some old
games in video game history month we did
toejam and earl last week goldeneye this
week if you have any suggestions for
what to do next week send them to me at
CT waters on twitter that's CT w ATT ers
and maybe we'll get a get some of your
suggestions can we play lemmings send it
to me on twitter tom that's all she
wrote I'll see you later everybody
everybody way to way to the folks at oh
alright